is it true and it seems unlikely that
you own a single piece of every bit of
memorabilia that they produced for Lord
of the Rings
oh well that's half true so I've got a
few things from the actual film so I
have the ring
I have sting I have a map from Bilbo's
study or the living room in Bag End and
I just recently because I went back and
did the final bit on The Hobbit and they
gave me the book that Bilbo writes in he
writes The Hobbit there in Mac again a
Hobbit's tale and then I finished it as
a lot of the reasons they gave me that
red volume which is Rob yeah
whoa and my last day in Hobbiton it was
pretty magical
I know amazing it's a real place
I saw the pictures of you all at the
premiere on Monday night oh yeah and I
mean it's been part of your life for
nigh on 14 years now so what's happenin
ocean light or where the emotions
happened already
yeah well it's over you know we're not
we've not been working on The Hobbit for
some time now but it was very moving I
mean you go and these kids have been
sleeping out all night what do you know
about this but these these people were
not born when we started making Lord of
the Rings No
so it's a big part of their lives and
that's that's very very sweet isn't it
and they'll be able to see all six
movies now and show them to their kids
that's what's nice we've made classics
and also it will take nearly a day to
watch it would Boland we're really sorry
I'm like poking with a stick but I want
to get my money's worth so good Gollum
introduced this lovely Gollum
introducing music tonight
like her name was Alison that acting was
good well you'll love Ian McKellan the
hob at the back of the five armies which
opens next Friday the 12th of December
now we saw the clip there hmm
and I mean some movies the title can be
misleading you know there's people
aren't run away by wind but but it
really it's you yes well I've seen the
movie so I agree with you but I thought
these armies it was just me and the
mates just pretending to fight but no I
don't know where they all come from
they're all in a computer on that but
they don't look it
so maybe no absolutely I must be real
well the ones close yes I suppose they
aren't the ones are actually fighting
yes don't ask me any more about that I
don't read anything about seen the movie
cuz then I understand the plot I mean I
had no idea
I don't know where we are in this show I
actually built it we built it for Lord
of the Rings we took all of the the
facades away and then it since been a
tourist attraction and now it's been
rebuilt for The Hobbit but with
sustainable materials with real woods so
it'll always be there so from now on
you'll actually get to see Hobbiton and
visit it as a real place stay there
Naoko but they are trying the green
dragon
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
yes we're going to Hobbiton for
Christmas I turned 19 when we first went
to Hobbiton and all 13 I was talking to
Pete when we were there on my last day I
said you realized that I had my 19th
birthday that it was going to take off
and be become a real place so I just we
were hanging around and we were in a
very beautiful part of New Zealand where
there was a sort of Mountain over there
in lovely sore big plains of lush green
grass and it was it was like a
picturesque it was like a a postcard of
what how beautiful New Zealand can be
but I said okay Eden if there was a gun
at your head you've got to do one of
these two things you've got to either
walk away from this scene not saying
anything to peace Jackson or anybody
else you just gotta walk away and go -
until you reach that mountain right and
not say anything to anyone and when they
say where's Ayden he's got a line you'll
just be fired over because no one would
have explained it and that'd be
certainly this job over and your name
won't be you know you wouldn't done
Poldark that's for sure
no or you've got to or you've got to
masturbate to completion just in front
of everyone here there's no there's no
introduction there's no
it's just you've got to do one of the
gonna get which one would you do and he
thought about and he chose the B he
chose B he wouldn't get fired but you
would get fired you should be fired for
that I mean if there's one thing I
believe it's you should be fired for
wanking on set yeah I'm dead against
that idea of people knowing who you were
where was it in the supermarket when you
had the yeah I was in you know the first
time that happened to me where I was
recognized by somebody yeah was it was
before Lord of the Rings had come out
and I was so I was like 23 or 22 or
something but I was walking through a
supermarket buying pasta and I'd done
some press and stuff I'll know the first
media come out I could correct myself
and this woman came up behind me and he
had only just released then she
whispered into my ear are you might help
encourage encodes to be nice to each
other and not to bully each other that's
a good thing to do particularly not to
bully the the gay kids in school or
indeed the gay members of staff and so I
was just leading onto a little clip yeah
I love this clip yeah yeah and so I was
rid the head teacher and and some of the
the senior students but outside that
they had teachers at window there was a
crowd of really small kids who wanted to
have a look so I I pulled up the blind
and had a chat with them so this is it
new bristle something there yeah and it
went viral kind of mmm
viral man know went all over the place
this is in at the school in your
preparation for your examinations if you
don't do your division properly do you
know what will happen
[Applause]
[Music]